welcome to video playing I am fighting
dragon Christian cocoa at the CM Russian
flag okay I have some idea against the
law Roxy that I want to test but they
all play that which is actually not that
critical but i have had not funny
business so it is critical against me
[Music]
let's see what he does I only know that
this exists Bishop to d7 and then be 585
but that's it I think this is this is
already possible playing for this for
this attack here usually you go h5 I'd
them okay I've never played there like
once the dragon a real dragon like that
when someone can cut along the white can
cancel know me always feel totally
scared this is exactly not my position
where they can attack my king doesn't
see what he does g4 looks extremely
brutal so this is a bit more more normal
maybe cancels long a five yeah probably
something like that is correct
yeah so we have the brutal approach yeah
not taking is probably impossible okay
if I take hear ya book h5 is going to
happen on immediately this old son maybe
the caption here it already looks
extremely dangerous to put it mildly
okay that looks wrong I know but maybe
maybe h6 even as possible age 6 is a
move oh my god this is a disaster at age
6 just wins I think if I cannot take it
he threatens to take I know that it's
just not my position and if you if you
don't know it yeah the age six wins
what's the deal why is he not just
playing it or am i overlooking something
very much possible I don't see what okay
i think the age 60 s was winning
completely winning ok so here he still
has a dangerous attack of course but
maybe I'm not lost
I want to age six winning I don't get it
okay over not relevant anymore so Bishop
f6 now or I can just remove the Queen
you should have six what's the deal
there go page five
right and I know this looks wrong if he
goes Bishop h6 now I have to check on h4
and let disrupt right enormously that
cannot be right look h5 takes h5 I don't
think that this works for white
objectively speaking 95 yeah Queen takes
is the thing yeah but as I can take here
I can absolutely take here look h5 and
then you look age 5 immediately is the
thing checking first is not a problem
and to do it anyway Queen d8 wasn't
possible and now this is the thing who
h5 he threatens 97 and clean h6 check on
frederick h eight which is pretty bad i
have checks on g 3n check on g3 some
probably a perpetual ok don't have
anything else no don't have a check
check
hook a chain is extremely extremely
tough check
all right I have to do it there's
nothing else check what how why is that
working okay so um what's going on here
and hey if i take here with the pawn 25
I'm getting mated Queen age five losers
okay I have this one this was clear and
then take the roof check check check
time morning
ok h one less be should be six I don't
believe that cannot even take now for
the pill
[Music]
check check check he's taking too long
here farm check point for it on town oh
that was extremely dangerous and I mean
extremely dangerous this is wrong I
think I wish is busted ah-6 lost is
winning I don't quite get it now mint is
full so what do you have to do you have
to g4 and then give if higher initially
but Dex 20 is no good anyway in such a
position yeah maybe five far I have no
idea let let's have a look this is a
thinking young more than dangerous ya
hear five I know h6 windsor as the
engine confirms there's simply no move
it took a long time time I'm not playing
it almost a minute yeah there's actually
not that much to calculate this is
immediately disastrous group hangs queen
age 60 h eight with made everything that
that's pretty clear and you know I
cannot take it come on up this claim
here yeah okay totally killed and if i
go back those hmm maybe you miss that I
don't know and then kill them
then it was it aged 60 1 and hear things
continue you should have six pretty much
have to i guess i'm emily has no Queen
Square I am square for the Queen just
just so funny I'm getting checkmated
decimal ok here take the eggs and the
engine gives the drawing line which is
probably logical now nexus5 could have
to take and this is very lucky that I
have all this route cheeks yeah now
check Queenie falls Jeff correct yeah
they are basically getting the same
position without the e porn that is not
bad and what I meant was wrong due to
what exactly check check yeah what he
played him check check check because
here is why just takes on this agony
when what he didn't do he is probably
better i am member cons are all weekend
and the big differences I could have had
this position without the e porn and
that makes a big difference as then F
and D pole are not so firmly stopped I
mean this is not an easy task for white
but he is definitely better yeah somehow
he lost control their orbits with them
with the time checking no check gr not
related sins can now play against this
unstable night air
in a min exchange up when I was
extremely lucky it's tougher to play
this this dragon structure without
having any theoretical knowledge I mean
failing there is usually meaning mate
yeah it's not not just like words you
just made it and that could have easily
happened okay thanks for watching